welcome to this video this is a new 2510
game and white against Frank Nautilus is
really low Rita Tim let's see what what
we get ya still as in the early stages
of that pool so we got a Queens gambit
tarish defense yeah i'm playing with him
well actually i recently had a look at a
line there with Bishop g5 that i found
interesting maybe i can do that like 93
96 and then Bishop g5 let's let's try
that it's an interesting sideline g3 is
the main move and probably the best move
but you don't have to play the absolute
main lines every game Bishop g5 is
interesting okay I'm going to take and
now do I go III or do I capture whom I
forgot it
I go III now him yeah well see for it
doesn't look very dangerous still I wait
if I take a actually can play deform
well not sure how good it is but anyway
b3 and sorry III c4b three what is the
problem their queen 85 I've works you
one now probably I can start with that
move him I just captures okay and so I
don't want to take with the pawn that
that's just too to drive oh he's trading
stuff that sits very comfortable than me
now g7 is attacked and I'm very quick
with pressurizing the deep on yeah I
cancelled hmm I wonder sugar I'm a group
t1 Bishop e6 he's got night f5 and
possibly d for coming or knight c6 and
then deform that's something to be well
maybe that is not maybe it is not that
Gilliam I think a look to you one but I
have to be always aware that Joan my
development of the Kings side is not so
great so you might have something like
Bishop e6 that looks pretty well not
forced but close to that and Queen a
five year that was the only other move
that I could think of but I wasn't
really sure that it helps if I could be
for now he will probably play Queen a
three
it's not great for him but so quite
quite messy so what to do I mean he
cannot play the night I'd always take
the five the normal-looking movers just
Bishop e2 I only one day ever have
something more more forceful and not
probably not so if he goes knight c6
next move I can go now various ideas
actually we can go to f4 but just to
detune
hmm i wonder if Bishop b5 maybe would
have been interesting just looking at
that see six square and be ready to
capture night once it comes to sex ain
again it wasn't really essential but
still interesting question so what now
he's ready to play in 96 and possibly
deform
yeah bishop every year it's there again
the simple move
Jim that looks very very normal but
still it's got knight c6 and possibly
deform
all rights notch it's not just that turn
that's straightforward still wonder
about that before idea but he probably
even can play going to be sick son now
beef before it's not not particularly
great i guess so any way to do it maybe
like a three can I voluntarily move the
Queen and just step out of that issue
Queen a form may be Queen a form and I
like that it also allows me to play
before under some circumstances like 96
Queen f4 Queen B 6 here seems that night
b5 was a move that it irritated him
okay not not very troubling for me that
he puts more on light squares yeah I'm
very good here with the attacking of a
porn I've got lots of pressure on it
blockading it's not as good I just hope
that I'm right in with the assumption
that he's not really getting to play
deform knight c6 clean f4d for think i
can really just take and that's
interesting you should have three and
have increased the pressure but also um
neglected see four square yep that's
true
so how to play it I wonder if I really
should regroup the night to be there
I'll control lofty for something like
Queen to d2 Queen d2 also hints at some
night discoveries hints at some like
night xt5 you can answer Rock t5 at the
moment so it's not not a huge problem
but some hmm
if I go you will go knight c6 and then D
5 D for so that's no good if i go back
to d2 preparing 92 you might have d form
he takes deep it should be three nah I
don't believe it so I don't think that
this is so great it also be seven
hanging so that's not so easy for them
to play deform yeah this has two ideas
sometimes night XD 5 is a move currently
it's not threatened because 95 we can
play look 25 and should be okay 95 look
25 Bishop takes d5 Quint XD to and
that's not not that great but still it
is some this is a possibility that he
has to take into account
yeah night to eat you then some aha it
seems that he was a bit irritated by
that prospect of nine txt five I don't
think it really threatened but yeah so
92 or is there something else one point
is that with the queer with the King on
a fade I might have moves that take age
seven tempo move I am a 92 was this the
technical way to do it let's just play
it in a technical fashion
yeah he didn't turn it didn't play and
play a bad chest this game to us it's a
bit passive Blacks game but it's not
it's not terribly bad or anything
against a very very good defender is
certainly will certainly be able to yeah
to to play this position in black and
not lose it it's it's a the bad thing
about it is that it's very one-sided
it's a very little hope for him to to
ever to have a win this game and it's
let's split pretty much clear it's just
too passive I'm keeping I'm still
keeping the option open to play nine to
33 if you place Luke see I'm sorry
brooke d to c 8 now anticipating 94 Luke
see one I will probably go Knight c3 and
increase the pressure
twist the pressure on that pawn yep why
not I'm not obliged to play 94 under all
circumstances of course I'm not really
threatening to take the five at the
moment technically speaking I am but at
the end of this line he will have work
to see to which should them be okay he
is active enough so even a move like I
know f6 or something um wouldn't just
give me the pawn I mean 95 everything
gets taken root C 2 I cannot go Rudy to
then because of the tray that works see
one back rang mate that's a thing ok so
he decided to go for them for the
passive approach um yeah so before I he
might take that I'm probably not before
sorry yeah I guess maybe like do I go g3
here to make sure that i'm not back when
mated maybe age three was also possible
is difficult to decide between g3 and h3
yeah I put up a purely passive defensive
formation sometimes though some pass up
setups really do hold I mean it's
largely unpopular and get yeah normally
bashed by chest commentators the purely
passive defense with some justification
but in some cases it really is the way
to do it just yes sit tight and try to
weather the storm I mean black really
has no active thing that he can do here
so he just has to be content with that
jump with that fortress-like setup let's
aim their fortresses mate is the wrong
word but as I said it's purely purely
defensive in nature yeah now eat things
a bit longer he was playing rather
quickly earlier and he played some
rather committal moves in known yeah
after very short time spent now he takes
a far longer I hope it's not a
disconnection or something that's
especially awkward yeah after the next
16 minutes of video the other guy
disconnects that's bad or would be bad
but then doesn't seem to be the case he
is just thinking form along the time
yeah am i threatening to check on d5
that's an interesting question probably
not on everything gets taken a true situ
again should be active enough black
black can play sort of a small
improvement move
it's not this now okay that was not
that's not necessary but but at the same
time it's not terrible okay getting the
king over here like King f1 kini to
maybe it's a bit difficult have many
many options you cannot move any of his
pieces they look to the sea file of
course but that's really all there is i
wonder how i should play from here Eve
pawn to e4 you can go possibly d 4 buddy
can also just take and taking a son
enough to convince me that it doesn't
lead anywhere I wonder this night no
probably not that a foreign idea was my
thought
now I understand he is not able to play
something active in this position how
can I increase my control here a little
bit I wonder what about Bishop g2 f-4s
that an idea Leonard shuang it's also
rather weakening
I'd like to use the King really that
would be great somehow get the King
centralized but I don't know if King
over to e2 is leading to much
yes said it's passive but it's still
it's not easy to to get anywhere I can
try what about if I get it's an
interesting idea let's try that night
night to see five
if I get night to c5 and possibly like I
mean be form it's something that I maybe
have to play a little bit later when I
don't see five would um pretty much
paralyze the whole Queen side he cannot
move the the beep on then yeah sorry for
that noise you probably heard that it's
my newer yeah coffee maker and sometimes
makes weird noises when it's hit it
switches off after a while if you after
you've made a coffee and make those
those noises okay wow that is not very
active to put it mildly so Wow um okay
so let's jump into it too not to c5
group d 697 loses the exchange so he has
to go to c7 and now let's that's
interesting now i have i mean i can take
now only six and play a form that's
definitely good form some advantage but
is it enough that's the real issue what
do I play before before the battles I go
before
it's difficult I mean if I can play 9702
the 25 one issue is if i take it 6 and
go before and you play something like 97
85 85 Bishop b5 everything gets traded
on d5 5595 route difficulty for up to
five and then we have a pure look and
gamma D plays rook c2 and I'm not
winning this at the end I that'sthat's
there the problem that store it still
has this this activity um I can play B
form one thing that I'm just thinking of
what is what happens actually if I'm
playing may I can look the king of
course they put a look of the sea for
threatening night x is six winning the
rook but you can move the king simply
I go before this Knight b6 that's real
nuisance
okay i can go for then 94 and looked you
three night beach was very awkward don't
have a great square Jabba taking e4 as I
said it's a bit it's a bit lame okay the
night be six looks like the most obvious
move 197 but Knight b6 has this night c4
idea so I'm expecting 9 p-6 not the
totally passive 97
yeah I want key ideas III to your form
in some cases i will do that like 90 74
looks good but if he goes Knight b6 and
that platform is going to go night c4
and I don't really have a great reply to
that he's [ __ ] a3 and d2 and rook to
e3 9 p-2 is quite embarrassing yeah so
Knight b6 I have to do something
something different one thing that I was
thinking of what's route de form so that
night before I can just take it because
of that pin on the D for them maybe 9
p-6 looks very m yeah very normal here
very obvious
here we go
mmm okay i won I mean look T for
intending eva is not bad just that I
wonder if there's something better what
is he playing after that moving like
let's say rook d to c 8 and it's not so
clear what my next move s then before
yeah maybe still before actually if he
takes it Bishop before the pressure on
b7 is quite substantial
okay roop dch I was thinking even then
II 4d takes e4 Bishop takes e4 and b7 is
tough to defend okay Ruby ate that
that's really really passive
yeah so I was thinking efore takes
Bishop jigs yeah I think I should do
that that was my plan hesitating them
probably no good
so I finished my coffee let's see what I
can do in this game ah so jump he has to
take it right it's no big alternative
otherwise I just take it on d5 I don't
see any meaningful yeah alternative I
mean some kind of counter attack or
anything it's really not obvious yeah
okay I'm going to take it you know
that's interesting I'm actually
threatening the porn on age 7 I didn't
really see that I was just thinking okay
the pressure on b7 is quite annoying but
I'm really threatening night xe6 every
six Bishop age seven ah that's very very
nice black resides wow he just resigned
okay wow you know you're on video you're
supposed to play it out ok it is a very
bad position but but still I was
expecting yeah him to continue yeah the
thing is I can really take that polar h7
it took me a long while to really
understand that but I can take it Ruby
eight and now I can just take antique
and this is really awkward what maybe I
can even take that immediately because
the tick taking is always problematic
because of g6 but yet it's not going to
be a problem at all so I can take age
seven just grab that and i still have
that very active position here let's do
a recap of that game so we got the
tirage Bishop g5 we should be seven
there should be seven is the most M
solid move there
there's also f6 for the more adventurous
people you know sometimes black really
has that option to go g5 um I think even
here it is a move but it's it's it's
very very sharp um Bishop e7 ticks ticks
and now I played here yeah I don't know
I mean I can also take but I wasn't sure
if that's a good idea so III and he took
on deform 90 x + 9 txt for that that's a
bit obligin to take because he simply
develops my queen and it's not a
particularly bad square on d4 I think
like castles or queen bee 6 those kind
of moves look more more normal and safe
yeah okay would you one here I went to
e2 looks also logical retaining that
option of the pressure cancelled route
e8 and a3 a3 was a kind of I don't know
what to do move a little bit I mean it
had some ideas but it it wasn't so clear
how to continue from here White has a
pretty obvious advantage but it's still
a small one yeah it's clear that white
is better but it's not a super super
great situation where I'm winning easily
or anything like that so I went here
small move I mean a 6 yeah that doesn't
hurt much but it also doesn't help much
Bishop every other the drawback is that
it neglects that square here but puts
pressure on the pawn rook here and Queen
d2 yeah the engine suggests this move I
was irritated by this but it's probably
not not really an issue okay I don't
think that this is particularly bad
Queen d2 looking away there that sets
helping me out
he was afraid of 95 but that wasn't
really threatening if you place a
slowish move I cannot really take
because of that yeah this is the best i
can get and that's not attractive at all
so he wasn't forced on it wasn't forced
to play king to evade okay i went to e2
came but keeps keep some advantage for
sure look there and now i went with the
doubling c8 yeah now that sets certainly
or maybe something that he didn't
anticipate that much it was maybe
thinking exclusively on that i play 94
but ok i didn't he went here and i
played g three years little improving
it's difficult to play it without any
any cubby hole for the king so has to be
played rock d8 yeah and in his sleigh I
think step-by-step worsening his
situation I'm not threatening on d5
again if he plays let's say this move
here I cannot really take care all right
maybe we can even have this here right
even even oops Bishop g4 sorry even this
is not bad but I was thinking that this
is also completely sufficient before
Rukia that's it let's draw right I mean
it's
let's be precise Ruby six you start with
a five even be five yeah and and that's
it I draw yeah okay black has to play
that still but it is it wrong that is
the best that you can get of course I
mean that that's really the best losing
that pawn under favorable circumstances
but I'm not threatening on d5 he can
really play a move that it's not giving
away this this idea 95 yeah night c8 not
that's probably think he can go back in
that case I have all the options I can
also just drop back to sue to his room
maybe after but this this is now just
noise I won't be four yeah this is also
an interesting move threatening 96
winning immediately with check
interesting I was thinking he can do
this but the comp points out a move like
this that's interesting intending to
double him yeah with a pretty good
advantage but before it's not bad Knight
b6 and they went to deform yeah the
engine wants to play a form but I didn't
like it yeah I saw that but I wasn't
entirely sure but you know if you
continue that line probably these six
will be very very strong
this one maybe check check
now black is struggling him yeah if for
would have been good this keeps an
advantage but maybe not the best
possible scenario now if all is very
strong young he has to improve here to
retain a playable position this is what
the engine is giving check wants to
return the pawn like that not return
give up the porn like that now okay
black hats drawing chance to see of
course the question is is it a draw
total draw and it's almost the same as
we have before yeah it's the same thing
it's the draw so that means that 97 was
a good was a good option I don't
necessarily have to check on d 7
immediately this move may be 49 f for
now he can defend much tougher this is
this is really giving me a huge edge now
because after taking as we have seen in
the game is basically lost and otherwise
I'm going to take and play d6 and then
the combined pressure here on b7 by the
night and the bishop will always be
decisive yeah he defended okay but just
a bit too passively it will it will
haunt you at the end you if you play too
passive a defense the likelihood that it
will will hold this some it's not so
high okay well thanks for watching